the big democratic debate exposes the
fields weaknesses president from
struggles with the fallout from rudy
giuliani's incompetence and from parents
erawan on syria i'm ben shapiro this is
Deven Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protects your online privacy
today like right now at expressvpn
dot-com /pun okay well we've got a ton
to get to today we will get to the recap
of the democratic 2020 debate and the
fallout therefrom
it appears that there is some roiling
tension inside that Democratic field
people are not satisfied with the field
they have honestly if Hillary Clinton
were to make her grand ring entrance now
would be about the time she should do it
because the fact is a lot of people are
dissatisfied with Biden a lot of people
are dissatisfied with Warren and Hillary
is an enormous name if you were to jump
in right now I think there's pretty good
shot she wins the nomination now is she
actually gonna do that probably not and
that means the Democratic field is
pretty extraordinarily weak so we'll get
to that in just a little bit but we
begin today with updates on impeachment
219 so according to the New York Times
president Trump's impeachment blockade
has now crumbled as witnesses agreed to
talk so the White House had said to the
house that we are not providing
witnesses to you and witnesses are
showing up anyway because they don't
really need the White House's permission
to show up as long as they are not
testifying to anything that is a
privileged material a week after
president Trump's lawyer Pat chip alone
sent a letter to the House Democrats
saying we're not cooperating according
to the New York Times it has become
clear the president Trump's attempts to
stonewall the democrat-led inquiry that
has imperiled his presidency and
ensnared much of his inner circle are
crumbling one by one a parade of Trump
administration career diplomats and
senior officials has offered a cascade
of revelations that's an overstatement
we haven't really seen a lot in the way
of revelations we've seen a lot of
perceptions by members of the Trump
administration who are sort of career
offices at the State Department that is
what we've seen and it is not
necessarily irrelevant but it's
certainly not dispositive right this is
not material where you you have a bunch
of people from the State Department
having inside information it's mostly
those people saying I was cut out of the
process and I'm really pissed about that
and I wish I hadn't been cut out of the
process and this shows the Trump is
corrupt well it could just show the
president Trump doesn't trust you
doesn't trust the State Department and
runs a very very closed ship with people
that he does trust which by the way is
1% true I mean that is what Trump has
been doing since day one to the chagrin
of many in the media and to the chagrin
of many who are sort of
professional politico's President Trump
has surrounded himself with family
members with immediate friends and this
is not worked out well for MC Michael :
in some ways but in other ways it is at
least kept the circle small
it means been incredibly leaky
administration there are a lot of people
in the administration who have been
serving from before this administration
who don't like Trump and that's been
perfectly obvious from the leaks it's
been perfectly obvious from the text
messages that we have seen from members
of the Trump intelligence community
texting each other I'm speaking here
specifically of Peter struck and Lisa
Paige yeah Trump in other in other words
has some fairly decent reasons to be
pretty suspicious of the people who were
in government before he was and so him
cutting State Department officials I
have a loop isn't necessarily proof of
corruption it could just be proof that
Trump doesn't trust any of these people
again my going theory on virtually
everything political is that you must
attribute to stupidity more than you
attribute to malice that you only
attribute something to malice when you
can't distribute it to stupidity and
when it comes to you president Trump's
dealings with Ukraine that one looks a
lot more to me yeah could be wrong we'll
see what the evidence says it looks more
to me like president from fumbling
around in Ukraine based on bad
information fed to him by Rudy Giuliani
then it does like president Trump
specifically attempting to leverage
Ukraine into quadrupled getting Joe
Biden in any case according to the New
York Times these accounts from various
career diplomats and senior officials
have corroborated and expanded upon key
aspects of the whistleblower complaint
that spawned the impeachment inquiry
into whether the president abused his
power to enlist Ukraine to help him in
the 2020 presidential election the
latest disclosures came on Wednesday
when a former top aide to Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo offered an insight
accounts of what he said was a
demoralized State Department where
career diplomats were sidelined and
others apparently were pressed to use
their posts to advance domestic
political objectives in six hours of
voluntary testimony the former aide
Michael McKinley told impeachment
investigators that he quit his post as
mr. Pompeo senior advisor amid mounting
frustrations over the Trump
administration's treatment of diplomats
and its failure to support them in the
face of the impeachment inquiry
according to a copy of his opening
remarks now again people frustrated at
the State Department that sort of the by
word of virtually every Republican
administration it's worse under this
administration but
time's that is fully justified I mean I
know for example the State Department
I'm over here in Israel the State
Department was supremely unhappy with
President Trump's decision to move the
embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv to the
capital the eternal capital of Israel
Jerusalem and tough and tough he was
right the State Department was wrong and
there have been a variety of
circumstances where the State Department
advised something Trump overruled them
sometimes he's right and sometimes he's
wrong but that's his prerogative these
presidents of the United States and if
your if your morale is low because you
don't like the president well suck it up
buttercup I mean the fact is you work
for a permanent branch of government and
you've been working there for a long
time now again this does not mean that
from did not do anything corrupt maybe
these people are demoralized because
they think Trump is corrupt again that's
their prerogative that's not proof he's
corrupt in any case Democrats on
Thursday are set to hear from Gordon
Sunland the US ambassador to the
European Union a central figure in the
president's pressure campaign on Ukraine
he is expected to testify that he
learned that mr. Trump did not invite
did not intend to invite President
zalenski of Ukraine to a meeting in the
Oval Office until zalenski pledged to
open an investigation that could benefit
Trump's political fortunes bolstering a
central allegation in the inquiry that
the president steered foreign policy for
political gain now remember this is
morphed a little bit originally it was
that he was withholding military aid in
order to pressure Ukraine now they're
making the claim that he was withholding
a meeting with zalenski in order to
pressure Ukraine to go get Biden it is
unclear whether he wanted to
quote-unquote target corruption in
Ukraine and he misperceived that as
including Biden or whatever he
specifically meant to get Biden that
last question is the one that only Rudy
Giuliani basically can answer which is
why Rudy's gonna be dragged up before a
House Committee Democratic lawmakers
according to the New York Times have
directed William Taylor one of the top
American diplomats in Ukraine to appear
before their committees next Tuesday
according to an official familiar with
the investigation text messages produced
as part of the inquiry suggest that
Taylor was deeply uneasy about what he
saw as an effort by Trump aides to use a
391 million dollar package of security
assistance as leverage over Ukraine for
political favors calling the notion
crazy well of course they want to call
him if you read his text messages he's
parroting basically everything that
Democrats are suggesting happened over
in Ukraine the White House has
successfully blocked a lot of the
documents tied to the case but
and his lawyers had hoped to use the
power of his office to muzzle current
and former diplomats and White House
aides arguing in presidential tweets and
a lengthy letter to Democratic lawmakers
on October 8th that their subpoenas are
invalid and unenforceable patch-up alone
of course as I mentioned wrote president
Trump cannot permit his administration
to participate in this partisan inquiry
under these circumstances but a bunch of
officials have testified for apparently
something like 36 total hours so does
that mean that they actually have the
goods on Trump no not at all not at all
it does not mean that by any stretch of
the imagination yet but this is
prompting Republicans to try and figure
out their own counselor strategy that
counselor strategy involves what is an
incredibly dumb idea apparently by
Lindsey Graham we'll get to that in just
one second first this talk of
impeachment Washington trade wars with
China the Fed cutting the interest rate
the perfect storm is brewing for a rally
in gold that is for sure uncertainty and
Cavs breed a rush to gold and right now
would be the time if this house of cards
our economy is built on collapse today
are you protected are your savings
protected because the fact is that
inflation can run roughshod over your
savings that uncertainty can run
roughshod over your stocks okay what is
your plan I've been telling you about
the precious metals IRA with Birch gold
group for years at this point they are
part of my family plan Birch gold see if
they should be part of your family's
planning let's take talking all it take
all your money and stuff it in a
mattress filled with gold or something
like that
I'm saying you should diversify into
precious metals at least a little bit
and make sure that you're protected
against the vicissitudes of the market
Birch gold will go to work and make
things super simple for you it's not a
complicated process they'll have a
conversation with you you can determine
if precious metals make sense for you
ask all of your questions get all of
your answers there's no obligation you
have nothing to lose to take that first
step perch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau text been to 47
47 47 today to see how simple and
straightforward the move can be for you
again that's been - 47 47 47 ok so
Lindsey Graham is responding to all of
this with what I think is a really
foolish idea apparently he has a plan to
send a letter to House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi warning that the Senate
Republican caucus will not remove
President Trump from office this is just
foolhardy in the extreme it's a letter
according to Graham's description warned
Pelosi that Senate Republicans will
vote to remove President Trump from
office because of a phone call where he
asked the Ukrainian government to look
into former Vice President Joe Biden and
his son hunter Biden the reason this is
a stupid stupid idea by Lindsey Graham
is twofold one how many Republicans are
actually gonna sign it if it's not all
the Republicans and then Trump looks
weak it looks like they're a bunch of
Republicans who are wavering on
impeachment when in reality they're just
waiting for more information which is
what all rational people should be doing
at this point right the fact is that we
don't know what happened with regard to
Ukraine you don't know I don't know only
Trump and Giuliani know well that means
that if you're a Republican senator the
last thing you want to do is say I am
stalwart Lee against impeachment and
then five seconds later Rudy Giuliani
gets up there and he says yeah it's
running around Ukraine sure sure and God
the last thing you want to do as a
Republican senator is put yourself out
there before all the evidence is out
because you don't know where this thing
is going now you can express publicly
that the evidence on the table does not
justify impeachment that is true the
evidence on the table does not justify
impeachment but to forecast in a letter
that you are never going to support
impeachment no matter what the
circumstance would be a foolish move and
to sign to not sign the letter would
also be a foolish political move because
then it looks as though you're not
supporting the president in the face of
a partisan driven impeachment inquiry so
Graham like what is the point of this
this is a very foolish move Senator John
Kennedy of Louisiana told the hill he'd
signed the letter if it is as described
but he warned it could be a distraction
he said I'll sign the letter that
doesn't mean I think it's necessarily a
good idea
we don't need distractions right now
Kennedy acknowledged there's a risk that
if the letter doesn't get enough
signatures that puts the GOP in a tough
spot he says the fact that some senators
may not sign the letter doesn't indicate
they don't support the president they
just want to hear more and I don't think
that's fair to them my worry Americans
will look at it and some less
enlightened members of the press will
look at it and say okay this is what the
vote will be among the Republicans that
is exactly right that is exactly right
so Graham my guess is probably that
Graham is doing this at trumps behest
they're probably Trump called up Graham
and said to him I want a letter in
Graham because he's trying to do his
best to defend the president and has
been sycophantic toward President Trump
to say the least
my guess is that Lindsey Graham was like
okay I can do that and then he just went
ahead and did it
but the fact is it is a very very bad
idea another GOP senator said he's
trying to help but it's gonna backfire
if there aren't enough signatures the
president is gonna look really weak and
that of course is true now in other
impeachment great developments the House
Oversight Committee is now asking a
federal appeals court to expedite the
enforcement of a subpoena for president
from financial records so if you thought
that this whole thing seems is like like
it's just a fishing expedition at this
point a deep-sea fishing expedition
that's right originally we were told
that this impeachment inquiry was going
to be focused laser focused right honing
in directly on the Ukraine stuff and now
we have the House Oversight Committee
who is delving into president Trump's
tax returns which last I checked those
returns precede his term in office the
ones that they are really looking for so
not sure what exactly they think they're
going to find there that the IRS hasn't
already seen the motion comes just days
after the US Court of Appeals for the DC
Circuit upheld the Oversight Committee
subpoena of the financial firm mizar's
in a sweeping victory for the House
Democrats the subpoena was issued
earlier this year prior to the launch of
the impeachment inquiry a three-judge
panel on the circuit court ruled Friday
that mizar's would have to turn over
eight years worth of trumps financial
records to the house committee Trump's
lawyers said this is a fishing
expedition we shouldn't have to turn it
over now they have appealed this to the
full court on the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals this probably probably ends up
at the Supreme Court level where we find
out whether the house does in fact have
plenary power over subpoena any
documents it could possibly want
including confidential proprietary
business information without any
evidence of underlying criminal activity
you know as I say a lot of this is gonna
come down to Rudy Giuliani and according
to CNN investigators are now looking
into Rudy Giuliani and accounts our
intelligence probe now this should make
all of us a little suspicious it should
make us wince a little bit why well
because the Trump Russian investigation
was launched under Counter Intelligence
auspices there it eventually turned into
a criminal investigation of President
Trump and his team but it was launched
under counterintelligence auspices
meaning that it was designed to look
into whether the Russian government was
interfering with the u.s. elections and
then it quickly turned into
from obstruction stuff that had nothing
to do with Russia per se well now you
have a counterintelligence investigation
that has been opened into Rudy Giuliani
this is going to lead president Trump to
believe more and more that the
quote-unquote deep state is out to get
him and his team because Rudy Giuliani
as his personal lawyer will get to more
of that in just one second first an
unfunded
over half of bankruptcies and mortgage
foreclosures are caused by medical
issues that's because if you get sick or
injured over the course of your career
your employer's sick leave may often
only cover for you up to maybe three
months and loss of income is really
connected obviously to medical problems
well health insurance helps with medical
bills it does not replace that lost
income and that's where disability
insurance comes in it's essentially
insurance for your income it protects
your paycheck of you're sidelined by an
illness or an injury and policy genius
which is your one-stop shop for
insurance is your best way to get this
policy genius does all the shopping for
you they compare quotes from the top
disability insurance companies to find
the best price then they're licensed
experts manage the application process
to save you time and hassle and policy
genius doesn't just make disability
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right life insurance at home
and auto insurance too so if you rely on
your income to get by head on over to
policy genius calm to compare disability
insurance quotes today they'll help you
protect your paycheck at a price that
makes sense policy genius it's the easy
way to compare and buy disability
insurance go check them out right now
over at policy genius comm your one-stop
shop for insurance okay so according to
CNN for months investigators looking
into read Giuliani's business dealings
in Ukraine have dug into everything from
possible financial entanglements with
alleged corrupt Ukrainian figures to
counterintelligence concerns raised by
some of those business ties according to
people briefed on the matter
the counterintelligence part of the
investigation indicates that FBI and
criminal prosecutors in Manhattan are
looking at a broader set of issues
related to Giuliani president Trump's
personal attorney than has been
previously reported
Kenneth McCallion a New York attorney
says that investigators first approached
him earlier this year to ask about
Giuliani's ties to left Paris and Igor
Froman too Giuliani associates indicted
last week on campaign finance related
charges
these guys were apparently some of the
people who are feeding Giuliani
information on corruption in Ukraine
mccallion says that FBI
counterintelligence agents in February
or March
asked questions about some of Giuliana's
Ukrainian business dealings the
counterintelligence probe hinges in
heart and whether a foreign influence
operation was trying to take advantage
of Giuliani's business ties in Ukraine
and with with with wealthy foreigners to
make inroads with the white house
according to one person briefed on the
matter Macallan says I was just asked
whether I or any of my clients knew of
any dealings these two guys had with
Giuliani they were on the radar with
regard to possible counselor
intelligence issues some of the FBI
agents and prosecutors handling the case
come from the same public corruption
unit the targeted Michael Cohen so from
the frying pan to the fire with the
personal lawyer ring for a president
Trump the investigators in the Southern
District of New York appeared to have
largely operated separately from what
Trump appointees at the Justice
Department headquarters in DC have
pursued in recent months the
investigation dates back far longer than
what's previously been reported because
Giuliani has long-standing relationships
in Ukraine and Ukraine of course is the
Wild West when it comes to everybody in
American politics getting apparent
there's a lot of money to be made if you
sort of had the right pockets and all
the rest of this Justice Department
officials said last month that criminal
division prosecutors in Washington had
examined from July call with the
Ukrainian president only for that narrow
issue of potential campaign finance
violations and determined this was not a
campaign finance violation but the issue
was far from closed meanwhile federal
prosecutors in New York are aggressively
pursuing broader issues related to
Ukraine matters and of course they are
now prosecuting for Giuliani associates
so Giuliani may be entangled in all of
this apparently former Texas Republican
representative Pete sessions has been
issued a subpoena by prosecutors
sessions wrote a letter to Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo to raise concerns
about the then US ambassador to Ukraine
who was later removed by President Trump
following complaints by Giuliani and
others so one of the questions here is
whether Giuliani and sessions were being
paid by these Ukrainian guys at the same
time they were pushing Trump to remove
Murray Ivanovitch who was the US
ambassador to Ukraine so now it's
possible this starts to look less like
Trump corruptly going after Joe Biden
and more like Rudy Giuliani corruptly
maybe corruptly feeding Trump bad
information or at the very least being
bamboozled while being paid at the same
time to feed Trump bad information that
he was then using to impact policy in
Ukraine John Bolton saw a lot of this
coming apparently just a few days ago
the New York Times it reported
that john bolton got into a tense
exchange on July 10th with Gordon
Sunland the Trump donor turned
ambassador to the EU who is working with
Giuliani to press Ukraine to investigate
Democrats according to three people who
heard the testimony Bolton's aide fiona
hill testified that bolton told her to
notify the chief lawyer for the national
security council about a rogue effort by
Sunland Giuliani and Mick Mulvaney the
acting White House chief of staff
according to people familiar with the
testimony bulton the ill trend lawyer
apparently told Hill to tell White House
lawyers quote I'm not part of whatever
drug deal some London Mulvaney are
cooking up which always sounds great it
was not the first time that Bolton had
expressed a grave concerns to hell about
the campaign being run by Giuliani
Giuliani's a hand-grenade who's gonna
blow everybody up
how quoted Bolton is saying during an
earlier conversation so again as I've
been saying literally for weeks at this
point this whole thing is going to come
down to Rudy Giuliani meanwhile Gordon
Sunland is set to testify and people
believe that someone was basically
Trump's Lackey in Europe according to a
former top White House foreign policy
adviser he told House impeachment
investigators this week she viewed
Gordon Sunland as totally unprepared for
his job that would be Fiona Hill the
same aide that we were talking about
with regard to John Bolton
she described Sunland a hotel yay and
Trump donor turned ambassador as
metaphorically driving an unfamiliar
place with no guardrails and no GPS
according to people who are not
authorized to publicly discuss that
deposition that took place behind a
closed door someone is set to testify
this week and we'll find out exactly
what he has to say one of the things he
is expected to talk about is the text
exchange that he had with Bill Taylor
another another official over in Ukraine
a min acting ambassador to Ukraine who
was asking sunlen like this looks like a
quid pro quo and someone tweeted back
texted back to him this isn't a quid pro
quo
he's expected to say Trump told me to
say that that it wasn't a quid pro quo
that it wasn't his own independent
opinion it wasn't a quid pro quo Trump
told me it's not a quid pro quo and I'm
telling you it's not a quid pro quo so
none of this is really wonderful looking
for president Trump John Bolton is
likely to be subpoenaed again it's gonna
come down to Giuliani right John Bolton
is increasingly likely to show up for
testimony but what's he going to say
that is that is new what's he going to
say that we don't already know from
these Press reports the answer is
probably not much it's all going to come
down to what Giuliani has to say and the
fact is that Trump appears to have been
fed bad information by a variety of
sources including Giuliani for example
yesterday in the middle of a press
conference President Trump went off on
the so-called DNC servers in Ukraine I
still asked the FBI where is the server
how come the FBI never got the server
from the DNC where is the server I want
to see the server let's see what's on
the server so the server they say is
held by a company whose primary
ownership individual is from Ukraine I'd
like to see the server I think it's very
important for this country to see the
server ok so the reason that he wants to
see the server supposedly is because
there is this theory that's going
through the crowd strike which was the
firm that was brought in to analyze the
hack on the DNC servers actually was
covering for the fact it was a Ukrainian
hack not a Russian hack Trump wants to
believe that because obviously he
doesn't like the idea that Russian
interference in the election shaped his
election in any way but there is not
good information that the DNC servers
are in Ukraine or really have anything
to do with Ukraine they were analyzed by
CrowdStrike it is not unusual for
servers to be analyzed by a third party
that is not in fact the government we
talked about this on the show a while
back so again you know it the I think
most realistic possibility with regards
to what we know so far is that President
Trump was misinformed by people who
should know better the president Trump
himself didn't necessarily know better
and that is why President Trump was
acting in a way that he thought that
there would be information behind these
various rocks and there was no
information behind the various rocks and
so there's an appearance of corruption
without actual corruption why well
because of basically being fed bad
information incompetence and and
failures of knowledge okay meanwhile the
president's Syrian policy is just a mess
unfortunately the president Syrian
policy has continued to unveil in
disastrous fashion there's video being
released yesterday by Russia today of
Russian troops that were over running a
u.s. basement it looks like the fall of
Saigon it's really it's really
ridiculous president
from is trying to defend himself also
there is there's more bad material being
released for Trump at least mature of
the mix Trump looked bad
with regard to Syria and I have to read
this letter so here's a president Trump
had this conversation with receipt
tie-up better to one via phone the
conversation of you know phone which
happened just about a week ago that that
conversation via phone basically had
aired on saying to him I wish you would
pull out of this area so we can attack
the Kurds cuz the turkey because the
Kurds are a bunch of terrorists and
Trump saying okay and then he pulls out
and then the Turks attacked and then
Trump is like well I wish they hadn't
done that and now we're gonna try and do
sanctions ok this policy was so bad that
the House voted yesterday to rebuke
President Trump over his decision to
withdraw those troops from northern
Syria the measure passed 354 260 260 all
60 votes against the resolution came
from Republicans but the majority of the
Republican caucus actually voted in
favor of the motion including the top
three House Republicans the resolution
was sponsored by the House Foreign
Affairs Committee Chairman eliot engel
and the panel's top Republican
representative Michael McCaul of Texas
and opposes the decision to end certain
US efforts to prevent Turkish military
operations against Syrian Kurdish forces
in Northeast Syria as we were reporting
yesterday the fact is that the Kurds are
now joining forces with Bashar Assad in
order to avoid anihilation at the hands
of the Turks meanwhile Isis fighters are
being freed because there is no one
there to watch them because no one
frankly cares about the Isis fighters
except for the United States it is a
disaster area now all of this all of
this this this entire phone call was
apparently pre sage by a letter that
President Trump sent to air21 on October
9th about a week before this phone call
and I have to redo this letter because I
mean if you love Trump this is what
makes you love Trump if you are lukewarm
on Trump then a lot of cringing and as
less here it is dear mr. president is
from Trump to everyone let's work out a
good deal exclamation point you don't
want to be responsible for slaughtering
thousands of people and I don't want to
be responsible for destroying the
Turkish economy and I will I've already
given you a little sample with respect
to pastor Brunson I have worked hard to
solve some of your problems don't let
the world down you can make a great deal
general is willing to negotiate
with you
he is willing to make concession that
they would never have made in the past
I'm confidentially enclosing a copy of
his letter to me just received history
will look upon you favorably if you get
that if you get this done the right and
humane way it will look upon you forever
as the devil if good things don't happen
don't be a tough guy don't be a fool
I will call you later sincerely Donald
Trump that's a lot yeah what now what
now presumably Trump released this lay
he sent it to trish regan so presumably
he sent this this letter to trish regan
because he thought it made him look good
it made him look tough on airline except
that he issued all of these empty
bloviating threats and then he
immediately pulled out a narrative on
just ran right over the guards i mean
that is let's work out a good deal don't
be a tough guy don't be a fool i will
call you later
what i got nothing
also why is he forwarding letters from
people that they don't want forwarded
like he's literally taking a letter from
the Kurds and he is forwarding it to the
Turks without the permission of the
Kurds presumably that's not a good look
well all of this resulted in a blow-up
at the White House yesterday because the
because the Democrats showed up at the
White House and they had this meeting
and they accused Trump of a meltdown
Trump accused them of a meltdown so we
have dueling meltdown
we have dueling meltdown statements here
Democratic congressional leaders
according to CNBC calm said they walked
out of a White House meeting Wednesday
on Syria after what House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi called
a meltdown after top Democrats left the
bipartisan meeting with Trump Pelosi
told reporters the president appeared
shaken up by a houseboat condemning his
decision to remove US forces from
northern Syria that's why we couldn't
continue in the meeting because he was
just not relating to the reality of it
Pelosi said outside the White House
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
described the meeting is more of a nasty
diatribe than a dialogue he said that
Trump called Pelosi a third-rate
politician though Pelosi later clarified
the president used the term at third
grade a politician House Majority House
Majority Leader Democrat of Maryland and
he had never seen a president treat so
disrespectfully a co-equal branch of
government well I mean Barack Obama used
to do that pretty routinely but not not
like calling people third grade
politicians or third
politicians or any of that Barack Obama
just used to basically call his
political opponents Tea Party terrorists
in any case House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy a Republican who voted for the
house measure to oppose pulling out of
northern Syria told reporters that
Pelosi stormed out of the meeting he
called her behavior unbecoming and
argued that Pelosi tried to make the
gathering unproductive the White House
declined to comment on Trump's
third-rate politician comment the vote
earlier Wednesday added to the pressure
on President Trump during meeting on
Wednesday Schumer brought up former
defense secretary James Madison's recent
comment that the ISIS what that Isis
will research in Syria Trump then called
the former US Marine Corps general Co
the world's most overrated general
saying he wasn't tough enough according
to NBC yeah I'm pretty sure that James
Madison have to prove his bona fide he's
in the toughness category Schumer urged
in the Senate to take up the resolution
as well prep president Trump also then
tweeted out about the Democrats so he
tweeted a picture of Nancy Pelosi
standing there and lecturing him and he
tweeted out nervous Nancy's unhinged
mount then and then he tweeted another
picture of Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi and Stinney Hoyer all looking
shell-shocked and he tweeted out do you
think they like me mean just top notch
drollery by the President of the United
States he also called Nancy Pelosi sick
after all of this he said Nancy Pelosi
needs help fast there's either something
wrong with her upstairs or she just
plain doesn't like our great country
shed a total mount down at the White
House today it was very sad to watch
pray for her she's a very sick person I
don't believe that President Trump is
gonna pray for Nancy Pelosi I'm just
gonna put that out there I don't
actually think that President Trump is
is going to get on his knees and pray to
God for the health of Nancy Pelosi
tonight pray for her she's a very sick
person okay so everything is going great
guys everything is going spectacularly
President Trump had some comments about
Turkey as well he said yesterday in a
press conference that the invasion of
northern Syria by the Turks has nothing
to do with us here as president from
commenting on all of this our soldiers
are not in harm's way as they shouldn't
be as two countries fight over land
that has nothing to do with us and the
Kurds are much safer right now but the
Kurds know how to fight and as I said
they're not angels they're not angels if
you take a look you have to go back and
take a look but they fought with us we
paid a lot of money for them to fight
with us and that's okay
and they did well when they fought with
us they didn't do so well when they
didn't fight with us yes that is the
point that if we left our soldiers there
they wouldn't be getting slaughtered and
then then Trump came out he said the PKK
which is a a communistic Kurdish terror
group that is on Turkey's border is
worse than Isis now they may be bad they
are not in fact worse than Isis that is
that is simply not true here is Trump
what does that have to do with the
United States of America if they're
fighting over Syria's land are we
supposed to fight a NATO member in order
that Syria who is not our friend keeps
their land I don't think so but Syria
does have a relationship with the Kurds
the thing that's common is that
everybody hates Isis now the PKK which
is a part of the Kurds as you know is
probably worse a terror and more of a
terrorist threat in many ways than Isis
so it's a very semi complicated not too
complicated if you're smart but it's a
semi complicated problem yeah I love the
parentheticals it's a semi complicated
not too complicated if you're smart but
like me but okay these are these are
talking points these are talking points
from air21 it is that simple Lindsey
Graham makes that clear these talking
points about the PKK we got nothing new
here the card should be grateful toss
that we were ever involved with them
it's bad foreign policy again a majority
of the Republican caucus in the house
just voted to condemn Trump over it
Lindsey Graham put out a statement
talking about president Trump's Syria
remark she said I will not have allies
in the future against radical Islam Isis
will reemerge on Iran's rise in Syria
will become a nightmare for Israel I
fear this is a complete and utter
national security disaster in the making
and I hope President Trump will adjust
his thinking well this of course
prompted President Trump then fire on
Lindsey Graham until Lindsey Graham to
stick to judges it's just it's a bad
policy decision it's a bad move by
President Trump and now he's doubling
down on it which is a in even worse
okay well all of all of this would be
bad news for Trump except for the fact
that the Democratic field is a complete
mess in the Democratic field continues
to be a complete mess and President
Trump has some systemic advantages which
we will discuss in just a second coming
up to 20/20 but first let's talk about
your sleep quality so I'm on the road
that means I am NOT sleeping all that
well one of the reasons I'm not sleeping
all that well I don't have my helix
sleep mattress it was personalized for
me customized for me it's back in the
United States while I'm in Israel so I
missed that mattress helix sleep has a
quiz it takes just 2 minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you no matter how you sleep on your side
on your back hot sleeper whatever helix
can make what your body needs just go to
helix sleep comm slash bend take their
two-minute sleep please they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life for
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will it's risk free and I mean
look what are you waiting for helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders just for our listeners
get up to 125 bucks off right now at
helix sleep comm slash pen that's helix
sleep comm slash Ben for up to 125
dollars off your mattress order helix
sleep calm slash Ben go check them out
right now again they make the world's
most comfortable mattress is so
comfortable that I actually got one for
my sister for her wedding it made a
great wedding present it is a fantastic
fantastic mattress it doesn't get better
than personalized and for you you have
customized everything in your life why
wouldn't you have customized the thing
that you sleep on for seven to nine
hours a night when that makes some sense
for you go check them out right now
helix sleep comm slash Ben okay in just
a second we'll get to the 2020
Democratic side of the aisle but first
go over to daily wire comm and subscribe
$9.99 a month ninety-nine bucks a year
you know the pitch plus the daily wires
long-awaited app is finally here it is a
first rate if you are a subscriber you
can access all of our contents including
articles shows and more straight from
the app all access subscribers get our
new and exclusive discussion features
where they can interact directly with us
I did one of these last night is
real-time it is fantastic it's great I
answered all of your questions in real
time if you subscribe you can do this
the app is available on Apple and
Android so download it today become a
subscriber and come join the fun we have
all sorts of goodies awaiting you and
the good
getting better and better month by month
go check us out 99 boxier also gets you
the greatest in all beverage vessels the
hot or cold left this tumbler left his
tears tumblr check this out look at this
beauty it's magical we deactivated the
cloaking device since we're here for a
while so go check all of that out and
please subscribe we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so president from does have
some systemic advantages going into 2020
Thomas Edsel who always writes
interesting stuff over the New York
Times he has a piece today called Trump
is winning the online war he says the
technical superiority and sophistication
of the president's digital campaign is a
hidden advantage of incumbency under the
management of Brad Parr scale the Trump
reelect machine has devoted millions
more than any individual Democrat to
increasingly sophisticated micro
targeting techniques the accompanying
chart compiled by the Wesleyan media
project describes the partisan gulf and
political spending through September
19th on Facebook and Google by leading
presidential candidates Trump sixteen
million dollars is more than the fifteen
point five million bucks spent by the
top three Democratic candidates combined
by the way the top spender in terms of
online media Tom Styer who spent six
point six million dollars that is money
that he just flushed it directly down
the toilet these figures substantially
understate how far Democrats are behind
Trump's operatives have been working
since 2016 to develop and test
techniques to identify voters determined
message effectiveness and develop tools
of electronic communication
Daniel Christ is a professor at
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
school journalism and mass communication
he said the fact is that Trump is an
incumbent we've had a significant
primary challenger that means that he
and his team and the Republican National
Committee have had three years to build
tools collect data test models and
messaging and mobilized supporters the
political director of the afl-cio
Michael Pat Pat hoarser is deeply
worried that Democrats have fallen
behind
apparently the Republican Party has
developed some technology called mobile
advertising IDs and in the use of mobile
advertising IDs that allow political
campaigns to basically track the unique
identifiers of voters phones and then
connect the information known about the
voter to messaging that they would like
to see all of this it means that the
Trump does have some endemic qualities
here that are going to that are going to
help him going into 2020 the thing
that's going to help him the most is the
fact that the Democratic field is
exceedingly weak now Elizabeth Warren is
the purported frontrunner in this race
Joe Biden went at her hammer and tongs
yesterday after the debate so the debate
happens and Biden Oxford moody judge
knocks her and clobber Charnock sir and
all of them knock her for a good reason
Joe Biden went after her
yesterday here was Joe Biden going after
both Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
saying that they are trying to con
people which of course is true pick on
Elizabeth Warren but this is this is
ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous the idea that
someone is going to be able to go out
and spend what's going to call it about
three point four trillion dollars a year
but Bernie Bernie doesn't play for half
his plan the last thing the Democrats
should be doing is playing Trump's game
and trying to con the American people I
think this is easy there's nothing easy
about it okay well that is a rational
statement that Joe Biden is making they
normally think oh that rational guy with
the big name ID why isn't he doing
better well probably because Joe Biden
still can't answer the questions about
Ukraine and his son Joe Biden said
yesterday that he never discussed
Ukraine with his son his son Hunter has
said the opposite he said that at least
once they did have a conversation about
his involvement in Ukraine here was Joe
Biden talking about this I never
discussed with my son anything having to
do with what was going on in Ukraine
that's a that's a fact and if I'm not
mistaken and I did not coordinate any of
this with my son I didn't even know he
was having these long discussions for
some time with ABC but he pointed out
the reason why he regrets it is he
didn't anticipate that that thugs like
Giuliani would use it to in fact try to
embarrass his father unless they are the
flat thugs and the reason why I'm
setting up the idea that I've laid out
has nothing to do with hunter
okay well the idea that he's laid out by
the way and it makes things awkward for
him is that relatives of presidential
candidates and and and people who are in
powers in office in in public office
that their relatives shouldn't benefit
from foreign connections like this yeah
that's kind of awkward cuz that your
Sunday in any case Biden is weak Buddha
judge went after born to Buddha judge is
experiencing a little bit of a media
boomlet
again after the last debate performance
because Buddha jej appeared to be more
rational than Elizabeth Warren Warren
again yesterday I talked about on the
show she kept throwing out all sorts of
radical plans then having no way of
defending them Buddha judge just dumped
all over her yesterday on the national
media was pretty amazing
not only is it important to have yes or
no answers to yes or no questions at a
time when people are so frustrated with
Washington speak but also there's still
been no explanation for a multi trillion
dollar hole in this plan I have a lot of
respect for Senator Warren but last
night she was more specific and
forthcoming about the number of selfies
she's taken then about how this plan is
going to be funded and that's a real
problem especially when there's a better
way to deliver health care coverage to
everybody
okay Budaj edge is getting a lot of
plaudits again the media are taking a
second look at bootie judge once you
start seeing people doing why not second
look at X you know the field is weak I
remember in 2012 there was there is this
thing that happened inside the
Republican field where everybody sort of
took a first look at candidates like
Newt Gingrich and Rick Santorum and they
were like and then they came around to
Romney and then it was like how about a
second look at Newt Gingrich and Rick
Santorum and by the time the primaries
were over was pretty obvious that Mitt
Romney was not world's strongest
candidate well Democrats are starting to
have exactly those same sort of
stomach-churning pepto bismal needing
feelings right now
because the stomach acid has to be given
them some sort of ulcer looking at this
field it's really bad the budding
impression of Elizabeth Warren is that
she's dishonest and that is a huge
problem for her because her core pitch
is that she's more honest than president
Trump she's gonna stand up for you she's
a populist who's gonna stand up for the
people she's not some Ivy League
professor who's sort of parachuting in
last-minute stealing Bernie's agenda and
pretending to care about the people
while being worth ten million dollars no
she is a true heart of the people lady
this is a woman who really understands
the problems of down-home folks right
that is Elizabeth Warren's pitch there's
only one problem and now turns out that
she lies about everything like about
everything so she lies about her
Medicare for all plan at least Sanders
is honest and she has now gone back and
deleted her tweet about Native American
DNA so as a post made one year ago
Tuesday at have were fixed at fifty six
thousand likes in a red my family
including FoxNews Watchers sat together
and talked about what they think of
Donald Trump's attacks on our heritage
and yes a famous geneticist to analyze
my DNA and concluded that it contains
Native American ancestry yeah
it turned out not so much I love that
attacks on our heritage on our
heritage one year ago she was still
claiming she's Native American after she
had the results of a test that said she
was one 1,024 Native American maximum
maximum okay that's it that's that's
amazing so she's gone back and she's
deleted that now why because she's a
damn liar not only is she a liar on that
she also lies on it turns out like kind
of everything it turns out that she's
wildly dishonest so here is an example
yesterday she was on CNN and she started
talking about how taxes was she she
refused to admit the taxes would go up
she said that Medicare for all would
reduce costs for middle-class families
which is actually not true and then she
told the story of a guy who she says was
refused insurance or was dumped from his
insurance after he was diagnosed with MS
here is the story she told then I'll
tell you what the actual story is I had
a young man stand up at a town hall and
explain that he'd been diagnosed with MS
and his insurance company refused to pay
for one of his treatments he'd started
down the treatment line and his
explanation of it was the Harry was he
had insurance he fights with his
insurance company no no no no no until
he finally ends up in public system but
understand this he described it as I
have now a lesion in my brain okay
there's one problem with this Tommy
Christopher points out that we actually
have tape of the guy talking and his
story is basically the opposite of the
story that she was telling his name was
Dillon and he said that it's quote you
say that you support Medicare for all
which does have a transition through to
get everyone covered on that however I
am someone who really relies on my
health insurance a lot more than most
people I live with an invisible illness
multiple sclerosis I've been denied
disability basically because in their
words they don't think I'm disabled
enough because of this I basically have
to constantly fight to keep my health
insurance over the summer I was kicked
off not my mistake but I had to pay for
it and about three months of me trying
to get my insurance back I was delayed
for my disease modified therapy which
now resulted in a new centimeter sized
lesion that's gonna follow me for life
because someone tried to save a few
bucks so my question is during the
transition it says over the first year
people with disabilities will be covered
will it be easier than the current
disability standards and basically make
it easier so that is a lot more
complicated as Tommy Christopher over at
media I points out then insurance
companies bad that's not exactly
happened he says it wasn't because he
said he says he says that insurance
companies frequently are and while Dylan
didn't go into detail about the reason
for the lapse it sounds like that could
have been the case here maybe it was a
paperwork snafu or a dispute over
payment he says it wasn't because of his
condition that's illegal right
Obamacare makes it illegal to kick you
off because of your condition she says
that he was kicked off because of his
condition
no his insurance laughed because he was
unemployed that is the and by the way
Medicare is as Christopher I'm shocked
I'm it was for wrote something that's
rational he says that Medicare is just
as devoted to saving money as insurance
companies and tonight's claims at a
higher rate than private insurers it was
the government that tried to save a few
bucks by denying Dylan's disability in
the first place this of course is
exactly right but Elizabeth Warren fibs
a lot the good news is she has her
defenders will defend her no matter what
one journalism professor actually
tweeted out that we need to stop asking
her about her tax increases because
journalism in intense levels of
journalist Jay Rosen journal was making
professor over at NYU he says the make
Elizabeth Warren say she would raise
taxes on the middle class question
should be a credibility credibility
killer for the journalists who keep
asking it why isn't that like a very
very obvious question that she refuses
to answer this field is is weak it is
weak and meanwhile the most humorous
development of the entire political day
Barack Obama has finally weighed in with
an endorsement in Canada in Canada if
you're Joe Biden you're like oh my god
Brock Oh Oh Brock said Joe I'm not gonna
endorse you I told you not to run
everybody does your role everybody knows
you're bad at this I told you over and
over I'm going to endorse another black
man Justin Trudeau oh no that's just
Justin Trudeau in blackface sorry in any
case he is now waded into the Canadian
election by the way no foreign
interference in elections unless Barack
Obama is endorsing Benjamin Netanyahu's
opponents in Israel or Justin Trudeau in
Canada otherwise no involvement oh he
also endorsed by the way Emmanuel macron
in France he's like he goes around
endorsing various political candidates
in other countries but he won't endorse
Joe Biden Joe Biden is the saddest man
in politics today it's it's well
deserved he spends his you spent the
last eight years basically massaging
Barack Obama's shoulders
telling him how wonderful he was and
Barack Obama's like I've got a big
announcement today got a big endorsement
in a big 2020 race Justin Trudeau there
it is Justin who don't ouch
ok time for a quick thing I like and
then a quick thing that I hate so things
that I like so yesterday amazing
experience and eye-opening experience my
family and I traveled over to have roan
Hebron in English and this is the oldest
biblical site present it is a it is the
site where Abraham bought land for the
grave of his wife Sarah at Martha
Michael Palin also known as the Cave of
the patriarchs really should be called
the caves of the patriarchs and the
matriarchs considering that buried at
this site according to according to
Jewish tradition and now according to
Muslim and Christian tradition as well
our Abraham and Sarah Isaac and Rebecca
and Jacob and Leah rachel is buried on
the road because she died on the road to
to Hebron in any case here's a picture I
was here yesterday it is a it is heparin
is a massive Palestinian city in terms
of the population it's about 215,000
Palestinians that 160 thousand of those
palestinians live under what is called
area c rule which would be the areas
that are governed by the palestinian
authority which means that if you are a
Jew and you walk in those areas will be
killed I mean there are giant red signs
on the side of the road that say if you
are an Israeli citizen do not walk into
the city really do not like literally
you will be killed and I asked my
security guys who are former Israeli
military and they say yeah it's not like
Israeli Arab villages where if you
wander in there no big deal right it's
just an Israeli Arab village if you walk
into Palestinian government areas and
you're a Jew you will be pulled out of
your car you will be murdered probably
at least it was very high shot of that
and there's been a lot of violence and
this is a lot of terrorism directed
against Jews in this particular area
well heparin has been the site of
repeated anti-jewish pogroms over the
years in 1929 and famously was the site
of a massive anti-jewish program that
basically wiped out the Jewish
population of Hebron now they're about a
thousand Jews who lived there they lived
and they live under Israeli protection
the specific area in which they live is
about 30,000 Arab Palestinians who are
living around them they're a bunch of
Israeli bases on the hills to protect
the Jews from being sniped upon
because that's what was happening the
the Arabs were sitting up on top of the
hills and sniping at the Jews and so the
Israeli government had to come in and
set up these bases look the people in
Hebron if they could live in an open
city and not in this tiny little ghetto
in the middle of a bran you think they
would you think they wouldn't you think
they wouldn't they wouldn't like to
interact with their Arab neighbors and
in fact some of their Arab neighbors
tribal leaders who are not under the
governance of the Palestinian Authority
do interact with them into events with
them but the fact is that the Israeli
government there's all sorts of myth
making about Hebron the Israeli
government for literally a one-block
stretch that we walked down yesterday
had to shut down some Arab shops
specifically because of security
concerns is one block yeah it's one
block heparin is the richest city in the
West Bank hey it is it is the richest
Arab city in the West Bank it is the
richest Palestinian city there's about
five billion shekel and export nearly
all of it to the State of Israel who
they supposedly hate and despise and
they have a massive shopping center with
like a KFC they have the entire shopping
area that was moved from this one street
in Hebron was moved like one block over
okay so the media covered this apartheid
state apart I say really the Jews would
be willing to live just fine with the
Arabs it is the Jews being killed by the
herbs that is the problem right it is
the fact that every time there is no
Israeli protection their jews end up
getting slaughtered there that happens
to be the problem also it is worth
noting that this this site which is the
second holiest site in Judaism right the
holiest site is the Temple Mount the
second holiest site is the Cave of the
patriarchs my Michaela when the Muslims
were in charge of it from 1267 to about
1967 when the Jews freed it in the
six-day war when they liberated it in
the six-day war for seven hundred years
Jews were not allowed to enter the holy
site for seven hundred years even after
that happened even after the Jews took
over heparin even after the Jews took
over my Michaela they still allowed the
Muslims to basically retain almost sole
control of the larger part of Mariana hi
Michaela this nearly 4,000 year old site
the the site is split sort of 8020
between the Arabs and the Jews the Jews
have like a small little synagogue and
the Arabs the I mean it's kind of
amazing the Muslims actually have
control of the area of Marah hi Michaela
that houses Isaac and Rebecca which
makes absolutely no sense because in the
Quran Isaac and Rebecca are not
important right in the Quran Ishmael
Ishmael is important
and Rebecca are not important at all but
the Muslims get the bigger area there
because it's the bigger area the Jews
are relegated to the smaller area with
the graves of Abraham and Sarah and
Jacob and Leia in any case the its it's
an incredible experience you see what
the people who are living there are
undergoing
for for those who don't understand the
conflict it's sort of necessary to go
there and to understand also the
thriving nature of the economy that is
not in the immediate area what you
usually see is left-wing NGOs who walk
down the street say why aren't there any
Arabs here why aren't any Arabs allowed
in here
ands like well because when they when
the Arab shops were open right there and
by the way there are Arabs who live like
right there they said when when the
Arabs had shops there there were routine
attacks on Jews here's a question why in
the other parts of Hebron the among the
other two hundred fifteen thousand
Palestinians either know Jews who live
there like none why is it that the
entire Palestinian world area is
entirely you'd and Ryan like Nazi like
you Dan Ryan why why is the twenty
percent of the population of Israel is
Arab and Muslim and why is it zero
percent of the population of the
Palestinian Authority run areas is
Jewish that is not because the Jews are
not interested in living in places like
Iran it's because the Jews will be
murdered if they live there yeah that's
why they have giant red signs that say
if you go here and you're an Israeli
citizen there's a high likelihood you
will die okay the it's it's pretty
incredible stuff it is an incredibly
holy site there's a lot of joy from the
thousands of people come in every year
around this time of year there's ten
days in which the Muslims get full
control of the Cave of the patriarchs or
ten days in which the Jews get full
control of the Cave of the patriarchs
yesterday was one of those days that big
concert outside was pretty amazing every
year around the biblical reading of
Kyocera which is the portion of the
Bible in which Sarah dies and Abraham
buys that specific plot where this is
again four thousand years ago which is
unbelievable that that about fifty
thousand Jews come and actually like
they'll stay in their cars because
there's no space there's literally no
space it's like three it's like a three
square block area there's no space at
all they literally come and they will
disconnect the battery in their cars
they're not violating the Sabbath and
they will sleep in their car so that
they can stay in the area for four
Kyocera it's a pretty amazing experience
and until you have actually walked it
and been there and
until and by the way Palestinian tour
guides will not take you to the
prosperous areas of Hebron what they'd
like to suggest that the Jude this 1,000
small area of Jews that that is what's
keeping the area port the area is not
poor Hebron again is a very wealthy city
by Palestinian Arab standards they won't
take you to the actual wealthy areas of
Hebron because that would give the lie
to the whole thing
in any case it's it's necessary to see
this to understand the nature of the
conflict to understand the historic
nature of the conflict and to understand
that the historic center of the Jewish
people which predates Islam by
approximately three thousand years is
here right is in Hebron and yet the
Palestinians who basically run the UN
World Heritage Organization the World
Heritage Commission declared this
historic site a Palestinian historic
site a Palestinian historic not a Jewish
historic site and they've tried to do
the same thing to the Temple Mount
obviously the the Obama administration
was helpful in in that latter area to
misunderstand the history that badly
takes a certain level of skill and or
anti-semitism or both already you know
we'll skip things I hate today because
that is both the thing I like anything I
hate I think and we will be back here a
little bit later today for two
additional hours of content I'm Ben
Shapiro you're listening to the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you